a lot of people have been asking me what
I think about the weird UFO sightings
popping up all over the country
Apparently one of the aircraft that we
shot down is shaped like a cylinder and
another one is shaped like an octagon
and people want to know is it the
Chinese is it aliens do aliens exist
Politico is reporting that UFO fever has
gripped Washington DC and so since
people keep asking I'll tell you my main
thought is that 50 Freight cars derailed
on Friday night in Ohio near the
Pennsylvania border leaking according to
reports at least a million pounds of
vinyl chloride which is an extremely
dangerous chemical and a known
carcinogen the safe exposure limit for
vinyl chloride is less than one part per
million after the derailment workers use
small explosives to blow a hole in the
rail cars to drain the vinyl chloride
which they collected in a trench and
then set on fire which seems to have
made an already enormous problem much
much worse because burning Vinyl
chloride since hydrochloric acid into
the air along with phosgene which you
may recall from history class is one of
the poison gases used during World War
One
seems like a pretty important news story
and yet it's not getting very much
coverage
we've just got UFO fever we're not we're
not really paying attention to these
other stories at least one reporter from
news Nation who tried to cover the story
in Ohio was actually arrested on the
scene
what are you trying foreign
pretty weird and while I am mildly
interested in China's latest Espionage
activities in the United States
I don't really care all that much about
UFOs
aliens aren't real
vinyl chloride is
and yet which one is everybody talking
about aliens aren't real
I know that's a controversial
observation to make in this they're not
real
there they do there is no evidence there
is zero evidence
empirical
or evidence that we can deduce
from our limited observations about the
natural world using human reason zero
evidence that extraterrestrial aliens
exist at all
some people say
that the universe is really really big
therefore aliens must exist that is a
non-sequitur it does not follow from the
universe is really really big that
aliens exist
the reason that people believe in aliens
now when people didn't used to believe
in aliens is not because of any new
scientific discovery there has been zero
exactly zero scientific discovery that
would suggest any increased likelihood
for the existence of aliens some people
will say well it's so large that
statistically there have to be aliens
that's not how statistics work
you might be able to make that argument
it might be somewhat persuasive if we
knew anything about the physical origins
of life we do not so there is zero
reason to believe that life certainly
not conscious life is cropped up
anywhere else in the universe it doesn't
matter how big the universe is the
universe could be infinite there would
not be any logical reason to believe
that it life's existence here
would would imply life elsewhere
this is a way for atheists and agnostics
to express religious longing and wonder
people will say well you you religious
people you believe in angels and demons
that's true there is much much more
evidence for Angels and Demons than
there is for extraterrestrial aliens
I don't want to belabor the point I'm
just so sick of the stupid UFO alien
stuff there's there's much much more
evidence for Angels and Demons because
angels and demons are pure spirit
that is the definition of what an angel
and a demon is and so if you believe
that spiritual things exist at all if
you believe that the human person has a
soul if you believe that some things
don't have a rational Soul like animals
and rocks and trees and stuff and that
certain beings do exhibit in a rational
Soul then the fact that the soul exists
could imply that there are beings that
are purely spiritual not purely physical
like
like rocks and stuff not hylomorphic
Body and Soul like human beings but pure
Spirit as well there is no the the
suggestion that aliens exist
pose certain theological problems
pertaining to the fall and Redemption of
the world
which is a discussion I suppose for
another time because it's somewhat
involved but all of which to say the
thing that everybody is focused on right
now is almost certainly not real and the
problems that we're ignoring are real so
what are the UFOs
according to the U.S Federal Aviation
Administration
we've got lots of weird UFOs flying
above our heads and I I love how last
week there was UFO fever and we found
out it was a Chinese spy balloon and we
found another Chinese spy balloon then
we found out that the Chinese have a
number of aircraft that we had not
previously detected flying over U.S
airspace and then a week later
we shoot down some aircraft and the
Pentagon won't give us too much
information about it and everyone says
well it's got to be ET
not that it's obviously more Chinese
aircraft the likes of which we were
seeing all of last week no no it's got
to be something totally different here
we go baby this is it the alien invasion
is on people only believe in the Alien
Invasion because they have given up the
other and more correct version of
eschatology the end of times so people
used to look up to the sky and wait for
the four horsemen to start flying down
in Christ to descend for the second
coming that used to be their vision of
the end of the world but now because
people have thrown away they've
convinced themselves that it's somehow
unreasonable to believe in true and
traditional religion now we're just
waiting for E.T to come down in a flying
saucer and zap the white house because
that's apparently more reasonable than
the uh True Religion that has animated
our civilization for two thousand years
yeah okay uh we had a potential object
detected over Montana Saturday night
the military shot down a cylindrical
object over Alaska it was about the size
of a small car so it was smaller than
those Chinese balloons last week
no aliens yet we can look at Area 51 but
no aliens have been discovered yet
a related point to my point about the
chemical spill in Ohio
we know that there is a little green man
type of alien that is causing lots of
trouble to our country
and yet we ignore that problem
and we we worry about the imaginary
little green men who don't exist and
don't post any problem to our country
there are millions of of aliens pouring
into our country every single year some
of them have tattooed their faces
entirely green and they're members of a
gang called MS-13 but we kind of ignore
that issue we don't really talk about
that one too much in the establishment
media because instead we're going to
distract ourselves with the E.T
people like to distract themselves with
Fantastical stories because it gives
them it gives them something to focus
their attention and worry on that they
can't actually do anything about we
could do something about our Southern
border and stop the little green aliens
who are currently coming in
we could do something about that but we
can't muster the political will to do it
we can't muster the political Unity
that's necessary to do that and so we
have to distract ourselves with
imaginary problems about which there is
nothing that one can possibly do
[Music]